one of my favorite debates of parents  right now is they say that their  children don't know how to act social  every child 8 to 12 to 17 is  dramatically more social than you  because when you were 12 and none of  your friends were around and it was 4 30  on a tuesday you went outside and threw  a ball against the wall so you may not  like the way they communicate but i  promise you they're the most social that  we've ever seen they're just using a  device and a platform that we didn't  have access to i know that the thing  that you're complaining about is going  to hurt your business because as we  continue to communicate that way the way  we recommend products and service will  continue to happen that way i want to  remind everybody this is not 2008  anymore this is not what's coming this  is what's happened